we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 David P I don't know what
I must have said to cause this but
someone called in and asked about how I
celebrate Christmas
hi David I know that your um Argentinian
Heritage is very important to you and
you're teaching your daughter
uh Spanish and all about that right
um so I was curious
um what does your holiday tradition look
like is it an Argentinian
Christmas or Hanukkah or a combination
of all those things or more of a
traditional looking American Christmas
um I'm just curious about what it what
it looks like or maybe there's a
specific tradition you Embrace yes I
embrace the tradition of Asian food on
Christmas I am uh I I'm Jewish
so there is no Christmas celebration in
my house my daughter will not be
celebrating Christmas because we aren't
Christian and and we don't celebrate
Christmas so it has nothing to do with
being Argentinian or an American citizen
or any of those different things the
tradition on Christmas is a Jewish
tradition where I believe even though
the default is often Chinese food
I believe Indian food is absolutely fine
on Christmas I've never gone for like
Thai or Cambodian or Vietnamese food on
Christmas but I think it would be fine
it's really whatever's open but
typically it is either Chinese food or
this particular Christmas uh it was
Indian food so that is going to be the
tradition and uh yeah I don't know what
I might have said that would have made
someone think I I celebrate Christmas
but I'm glad to answer questions about
Indian or Chinese food at any time we
have a great bonus show for you today
the sacks uh the sax the sex trafficking
saxophone the sex trafficking
investigation into Republican Matt Gates
is being dropped oh the bonus show where
you want to make everybody
Matt Gates will not be charged we will
talk about it new childhood obesity
guidance is Raising concerns over the
risk of eating disorders and the
Democrat who nearly unseated Lauren
bobert Adam Frisch has announced he is
running against her again in 2024. it
came down to just such a small margin
what can we do to really be sure we
remove Beau bear in 24 Is it wise for
Adam Frisch to announce his candidacy so
early or not we are going to talk about
all of that on today's bonus show I
would really love for you to become a
member not just because you'll get
access to the bonus show but because we
do depend on members to fund the program
our primary funding source the plurality
of our dollars come from the membership
program you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now and boy has it
started 24 starts now that's 2-4 starts
now all one word to get a discount off
of a membership you'll get access to the
bonus show the commercial free audio and
video feeds of the show invitations to
the members only town halls and access
to the members only soundboard when I
play the clips nuclear collaboration
right
yes that is a freaking Predator right
there that soundboard we make available
to our members so all great benefits to
take advantage of sign up at
joinpakman.com and remember if you have
a parent a friend whatever
who could use some American political
commentary in Spanish the Spanish
YouTube channel has launched it is at
davidpackman.com
Spanish we're working on our first
thousand subscribers there it's an
exciting new project make sure whoever
it is that would prefer to consume this
sort of content in Spanish rather than
English is aware of it davidpackman.com
Spanish I will see you on the bonus show
my friends